how does the hero's journey help writers
develop complex characters
oh the hero's journey is really useful
for giving depth and dimension because
it asks a lot of questions uh that may
not occur to the writer at first when
you just dream up a character
the hero's journey suggests that there
is a back story that the hero came from
somewhere that the hero is in some kind
of a relationship to his or her world at
the beginning and that there's something
a little bit out of balance about that
and then there is a barrage of
impediments and obstacles and
challenging people or energies that
enter into it and make life very
complicated for the hero there's a
villain who has often who has different
Ambitions and desires than the hero
perhaps exactly contradicting with the
hero's wishes and then other characters
who have their own agendas some to make
fun of the hero some to give him some
grief in the Romantic department
or some other area and
so it it gives a lot of
a lot of scaffolding for people to work
out and ask questions about the heroes
I've just been doing some Consulting
on student films in Denmark I went to a
film school there and also had just been
working with a Hollywood production and
they all want to know you know what is
the hero's journey say about my story so
they've laid out certain steps but they
want to know
what uh uh what are the possibilities
within the structure that they've
created so there they usually come to me
for that kind of uh alternate
possibility thinking because I've
developed by looking at thousands and
thousands of scripts uh examples I've
developed sort of a drop down menu about
everything that if you come to a certain
Crossroads uh there's one kind of
obvious thing that can happen but then
there's all these other not so obvious
things that could happen other
possibilities and I know that that list
is theoretically infinite because I keep
thinking I've come to the end of it and
I'll be watching some wonderful show
that I love and I'm thinking well I know
at this Crossroads they could do this
this and this those are the only four
possibilities and then the filmmaker
does five six seven that I didn't think
of and I love it that's a thrill to me
to to see my pattern as I understand it
expand and you know to add an extra
decorative two of possibilities just is
a great thrill to me so I think the the
mythical mythological way of looking at
things is uh
really a practical
guidance for writers you know that uh it
it lets them think a little outside of
the box and also provide mythological
examples and that's part of how I
operate people treat me like a
mythological cash machine where you know
they put the card in and then I'm
supposed to like a ticker tape is
supposed to come out that says when
you're dealing with snakes and uh Stones
uh what kind of myths have to do with
that and then they'll listen to me tell
some ancient story that relates to it
and they'll go ah that I could do that
that's interesting you know they'll take
a piece out of some myth or fairy tale
and apply it to their let's say modern
day story and I just find that
delightful that that this old dusty
stuff still can spark things in modern
creators I think that's just terrific
what are the key elements of compelling
character ah character that's a whole
subject that
I didn't deal with very much in my
original book except in the sense of
looking at these archetypes as you know
seven or eight different aspects of uh
possibilities for characters and I'm
going at it again from a different point
of view trying to understand that word
character and as I always do I like to
excavate and go back to the original
meaning of the word when they made up
the word what were they thinking about
and what did it mean way back when so
with character you trace it back it's
actually a Greek word spelled slightly
differently but it's the same word
character
the original meaning of the word was
that a character was either the tool
that made the impression or the
impression itself like with cuneiform
lettering where you take a stick and you
make wedge-shaped marks to indicate you
know how many sheep or how many bales of
hay
that those marks or those imprints were
what they called character and then by
way of metaphor
the Greeks started thinking about well
human beings have those marks too human
beings have characters uh impressed on
them the the blows of Life the kind of
the good things that are dealt out and
the bad things that are dealt out leave
Impressions they leave marks on you and
then also you leave marks on the World
Around You by how you react to what's
been dealt out to you so they put all of
that together the marks the world makes
on you and the mark you leave on the
world that equals your character and
they had a very elaborate system of
understanding this which in sort of the
typical Greek way was very humanistic
what I mean is they couldn't really deal
with abstract Concepts except to put
them in human terms so if they're
dealing with an abstract concept like
justice or revenge or Excellence
or struggle
uh the only way they could really get a
grip on it was to turn it into a human
character and say uh let's tell some
stories about the goddess of Victory uh
the god of struggle uh the god of good
timing the goddess of luck of Fortune uh
the gods of Vengeance and retribution uh
the goddess of Justice
and so they they took these abstract
qualities human characteristics and
turned them into characters
that they can tell stories about and so
this is an area that I'm studying now is
um uh
what goes into making a character that
we create as an imaginary person but
also what goes into their character what
goes into making up
um the nature of of that imaginary
creation so everybody's got a character
which is a mix of the way the world sees
you like your reputation but also how
you really are inside the things you
will do and won't do the behaviors that
are your downfalls or your virtues
all those things go into making up your
character so this is what I'm studying
now and and looking at uh seven or eight
of those uh
gods and goddesses that are the Greek
way of understanding these human
characteristics the one I really got
started on was Arete who was a goddess
of excellence and they had they used
that word Arete to mean somebody has got
a retake they've they've got that
quality they're just excellent as a
speaker or as a law Giver or as a father
or mother
or cook you know they they just they're
really good and and that was called
irate but then they had this story about
arrete who was a goddess
who guided people on the path of virtue
and they even made up a uh evil twin for
her who was called kakya and she was the
bad version of Excellence maybe
Excellence that is perverted uh that
you're excellent at all costs and you're
you want to be excellent at something so
much that you'll walk on other people's
heads to get there uh or that you take
the lazy way instead of the path of
difficulty and Challenge and excellence
so this is just for me a wonderful
lens you know that I use to look at
these qualities and I'm trying to gather
ideas about it to help writers to
compose
characters who have some of these
qualities and just asking themselves
asking the writers I'm asking the
writers to ask themselves
have I considered my character's
attitude towards Justice my character's
attitude towards Excellence my
character's attitude towards Revenge uh
so this is me the new area for me that
I'm exploring and have you applied some
of that back onto the original example
that we talked about the Cary Grant
character in The Hitchcock film where
you you there was something amiss and
you couldn't figure out why he was
coming at it a certain way sure well in
that example from Hitchcock and
notorious Cary Grant is ruled by two
Gods at once and one of them is Amore
the god of love or Venus the goddess of
love and he's got a gorgeous perfect
personification of Venus right in the
room there with him calling him to give
up uh this other path but the other God
that he serves is the god of Duty and I
haven't figured out or analyzed yet what
that is in the Greek language but
um or or the cast of characters but he
is clearly torn between those two and
that's a great thing to do to a
character is to give them two gods that
they are equally bound to and but
they're in conflict and this is a great
place to to put a character so I think
Cary Grant is trying to figure out which
God he's going to serve and makes the
mistake of serving the god of Duty for
most of the movie but in the end he
realizes he strung away a treasure and
he sets aside the uh the the duty in
order to
honor the god of love or the goddess of
love